hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
this is oneplus 8.
now if oneplus didn't just also come out
with a oneplus 8 pro
this is the phone oneplus would mark it
as
flagship killer right but we all see
oneplus slowly moving away from that
direction now they have a different
slogan fast and smooth and you can tell
they're getting away from the flagship
killer thing now that they actually make
a flagship
but this is exactly what i would expect
from the oneplus that i feel like we've
always known so this interstellar glow
oneplus 8 starts at 6.99 and it has the
bleeding edge high-end specs you'd want
for fast performance snapdragon 865 with
the 5g modems in there 8 or 12 gigs of
fast ram
ufs 3.0 storage wi-fi 6. like that's all
nice it's a fast phone definitely love
that but there are a few things here
cut down
to save cost and i'll compare this a lot
to the oneplus 8 pro so if you haven't
watched that as the previous video
firstly the like button if you want to
watch it to catch up that's there but
the story is if you worked for oneplus
and you started off with this
900 to thousand dollar phone and you're
like all right
what are we going to cut out of this
phone
to get the price way down
but still give people a pretty close to
a flagship experience
what would we do
well this is what they did first of all
it's overall a bit of a smaller form
factor now it's by no means a small
phone it's definitely still big it has a
6.55 inch display which makes it still a
little taller than the iphone 11 pro max
so it's not small but it is a little bit
smaller than the 8 pro and it's also
definitely lighter it's noticeably
lighter to me it's 180 grams on paper to
be exact
and to me it feels comfortable in the
hand then there's that display it still
has the optical fingerprint reader
underneath it's still hdr10 plus
certified and still super color accurate
and much brighter than last year which
is key so it's super visible outdoors
but now
it's a 1080p resolution instead of 1440
that's a smart move that they've done in
the past and it's also now high refresh
rate at 90 hertz instead of 120 hertz
i'd love to get blind tested on this but
i've said i can personally see the
difference between 90 and 120 hertz but
it's small and you have to be looking
for it but i'll definitely prefer either
of those to 60 hertz because that
difference is visually huge so this is
still high refresh rate so this is a
cost saving trade-off that makes perfect
sense it's still a really smooth
responsive screen we've seen other
phones bring high refresh rate down in
price so it doesn't really make this one
stand out anymore like it used to but
that's not a complaint at all i'm
clearly a fan of high refresh rate and
i'm glad to see it everywhere plus if
you're if you're still in the mindset of
you work for oneplus and you're trying
to cut down on things you get to say you
know high refresh rate and high
resolution are nice
but if you go too high on those things
you cut into battery life so we're
giving you 90 hertz and 1080p and that's
a good balance to still give you fast
and smooth while being friendly to your
battery and that's turned out to be
absolutely true this phone has a 4300
milliamp hour battery and it's been
impressively good on battery life
lasting me easily through the end of
every day i've tested it with like 15 to
20 percent left over so it's honestly
slightly better battery life than the 8
pro which i've been running maxed out so
i guess i should expect that so then
there's three more trade-offs
ip68
wireless charging
and the cameras the oneplus 8 doesn't
have an ip68 water and dust resistance
certification but this is another one of
those instances where oneplus would
probably claim they've put the necessary
seals and pieces inside the phone and
tested it themselves but then passed on
the savings of not getting it officially
tested
i don't know about that i haven't tested
mine i'll i'll wait for the jrig
everything test to see those seals thank
you very much but then this phone
straight up doesn't have wireless
charging
at all same deals last year it has a
glass back but it doesn't have the
wireless charging coil to take advantage
of that glass back now at 700 bucks
there are a way lower number of phones
at this price that don't have wireless
charging so it's much harder to justify
but that's always been i guess oneplus
thing you know saying wireless charging
isn't fast enough for their standards so
again there's still fast wire charging
here still warp charge 30t
so zero to 50 in 25 minutes and it's
included in the box too so all that good
stuff but yeah no wireless charging it
kind of makes me wonder
how much
per unit like that would cost like could
they have just swallowed their pride and
put in just an ordinary wireless
charging coil on the phone and just been
like you know what finally we added it
probably
but you know then again they are trying
to save money but anyway last but not
least there is a different and lesser
camera array in the oneplus 8. on paper
it's a 48 megapixel main sensor and a
different one from the pro then a 16
megapixel ultrawide camera and a
dedicated 2 megapixel macro
no telephoto and to me that's the
correct one to leave out but it's funny
there's still a telephoto button in the
camera app which punches into 2x but
like lg did with the v60 that's just a
digital crop in from the main sensor
which honestly looks just as good if not
better than a cheap telephoto would have
now this dedicated macro camera it's
kind of fun but honestly not very good
quality and i'm not just saying that
because it's 2 megapixels like it's just
lacking quality it's not a great dynamic
range and not great color overall
quality is pretty lacking
so you know i had some fun taking some
macros with it but i think it's one of
those cameras that you'd forget about
after the first week and then the main
camera it does have a 48 megapixel
number attached to it but again it's a
step down from flagship quality and
sharpness and detail and in colors and
just overall performance i mean it feels
like the classic oneplus of the past
amazing everything else on the phone
sub-par camera honestly if you're
serious about camera quality you
probably shouldn't be looking at this
phone you should check out something
like the pixel 3a or even the brand new
air quotes brand new uh iphone se which
looks like it'll have a flagship quality
camera for 3.99 an iphone quality camera
for 3.99 so definitely stay tuned for
the video when i get my hands on that
phone very soon it should be a fun video
also in case you've been wondering
what color this phone is just because
it's it's look like a different color
and like every shot in this video this
interstellar glow
uh is
a nightmare honestly it's definitely
unique i'll give it that um this finish
underneath the glass gives it a
different refraction index from
different angles you get all kinds of
wild colors reflecting off of it but
it's a hundred percent one of those
phones that looks better on camera and
in promos than it does in real life this
thing catches more fingerprints than the
csi agent of the month do i even
do i even have to make this segue
dangerously close to linus territory
look you should you should consider
something a little more low-key channel
sponsored d brand will help you clean up
your act if you accidentally pull the
trigger on this colorway of the phone
personally i think this black camo looks
pretty tight so all right here's my
summary for one plus eight aside from
the crazy color i really like this phone
it's got a great display it's great
performer for the price obviously really
high end specs it's not the king for
this price but it's great performer it's
got fast charging it's included in the
box it's got oxygen os 2 which i've
talked about in the past as one of my
favorite android overlays and they
frequently get software updates too so
it's it's a clean package i could tailor
this phone right now and i'd probably be
super happy it also happens to be one of
the absolute cheapest 5g compatible
phones
on the market right now it's not why i
would buy it but that is a nice bonus
for longevity having the phone for four
or five years but it's not it's not
amazing it's not it's not some special
phone
like it used to be and really it's the
stratification of phone prices over
these past couple years that has caused
this situation like i remember this just
a couple years ago maybe it was longer
than i think but high-end phones used to
just be like five 600 maybe 650 bucks
700 bucks and so it felt like you were
either reaching for racing for the top
for the absolute highest end bleeding
edge best phone or racing to the bottom
for the cheapest phone the best budget
phone and so oneplus came along and this
sort of slipped right in the middle they
were undercutting the flagships they
positioned themselves as flagship
killers because they were somewhere in
the middle but now today we have what
like 200 to 300
budget phones we have our 400 500 600
mid-range phones then we have our seven
eight nine hundred dollar premium phones
then we have our thousand eleven hundred
fourteen hundred dollar ultra premium
flagship phones
and so there's more chaos there's more
activity than ever at like all of these
different price ranges so today at this
price for 6.99 you could get this
or you could get if you wanted a smaller
phone you could get galaxy s10e
or if you absolutely had to have 120hz
you could get the pocophone x2
or if you had to have a gaming phone you
could get the red magic phone or if you
absolutely wanted the best camera
quality you should go for pixel 3a or
even the new iphone se plus
airpods pro plus a wireless charger i
usually don't go super in-depth with
price in my reviews just because that is
one of those things that usually changes
over time
but i think that's uh that's something
i'm going to be changing now just
because the positioning of these phones
maybe ever since like the essential
phone sometimes is the reason why they
uh they live or die but yeah oneplus 8
it's a nice phone it's not special
anymore but it is one of the favorites
in this awkward middle child price point
of 6.99 to start
but yeah look around there's a whole
landscape out there thanks to the
stratification of pricing i guess but
maybe you can watch other videos about
those other options too
either way thanks for watching this one
catch you guys in the next one very soon
peace